in the uk which has been a big leading  indicator i i don't know that there's  any country that has better predicted  what happens in the us  than the uk throughout the pandemic the  uk's daily case numbers are now back up  to about 60 70 000 cases per day and  there's a question as to whether that's  as high as it's going to go or whether  it's going to continue climbing  italy which remember at the very  beginning italy had one of the worst  spikes that spike when we now look back  looks like nothing it look it looks  almost completely flat in april of 2020  and that was outdone in november of 2020  and of course overwhelmingly outdone by  the omicron spike italy is now higher  than at any point other than the omicron  spike  these are really really ugly numbers